ucrania le ha pedido a turquía que
investigue la procedencia de cuatro
buques rusos que transitan por lo
general por turquía a través del
estrecho del bósforo para la dirección a
puertos turcos y sirios y que
supuestamente llevan carga que es trigo
robado de los silos y puertos soberanos
conquistados por rusia durante esta
invasión rusa que empezó el 24 de
febrero de 2022 uno de estos buques está
siendo investigado ahora mismo según ha
confirmado las autoridades turcas en el
puerto de cara sur muy cerca de estambul
en el mar negro a unos pocos kilómetros
al norte de donde nos encontramos
actualmente los demás buques sin embargo
no están en turquía pero podrían pasar
en las próximas fechas a través del
estrecho del bósforo por donde ya han
transitado en varias ocasiones desde
febrero
turquía ha asegurado que nunca ha
comprado trigo ha robado procedente de
ucrania a través de buques rusos sin
embargo muchos expertos consideran que
sí lo ha hecho y según imágenes de
amistad han mostrado como estos buques
que señala ahora mismo ucrania salieron
de los puertos de sebastopol en la
crimea ocupada desde 2014 por rusia o
del puerto de verdi ans a unos pocos
kilómetros de mariupol ciudad
conquistada en abril de este año en
dirección a puertos tanto turcos han
descargado a su cargo también en puertos
de siria de damasco donde es vendida al
régimen de bashar al-assad el presidente
sirio y al aliado de rusia en oriente
medio